and you hear me okay good afternoon I
hope you are fresh and not tired from
lunch thank you for the organization of
this workshop it's my pleasure to be
here so in my talk I want to report
about the joint work with Christian
Akuma and greater Pune Pandava who are
both here and but of course the story
starts at the beginning so let me recall
what this is all about even though I'm
aware you all know it but still let me
recall the permanent versus determinant
problem so here we have the permanent we
know it we have an end M by M matrix the
end these are variables this is
definition of the permanent how many
arithmetic operations are needed to do
this
the best-known algorithm that we know
take exponentially many operations but
the determinant we all know it can be
evaluated efficiently and we would want
to understand what is the difference so
in all of the talk I will work in
character is ero in actual over the
complex numbers so Valiants conjecture
we also know that but let me
nevertheless recall it so Leslie valiant
asked the following question so can we
write the permanent as a determinant of
a possibly bigger matrix then the
entries are linear functions so this
formulation is the homogenous
formulation so I have the variables X IJ
and square variables an initial variable
Z and the entries of this matrix a IJ or
homogeneous linear forms okay then on
the on the left hand side I have to I
multiply with this power of Z so in
order so that this thing will be
homogeneous of degree n so the question
is is this possible and if I well it's
possible about how big has n to be in
depends on M in order to make this
possible okay so it's interesting to
know that power
a long long time ago looked at this
question for M equals M and they showed
it's impossible then speaking to Leslie
valiant he proved it's possible if n is
exponential in M and there is this very
nice construction by Bruno Groening
showing that 2 to the M minus 1 is
enough yes without well without a Z I
mean some if you subsidize the Z by 1
then you get the original phrasing of
the conjecture it's the this is just
written homogeneous way it's completely
equivalent otherwise ok the only novel
out lower boundary known is 1/2 M
Squared this is the result Padmini under
said that's the sad state of the affairs
ok
and there is this famous valiance
conjecture from 79 which states well
it's impossible to have such a relation
star if n is polynomially bounded enable
ok we all know that we also know that
this conjecture is equivalent to the
separation of two complexity classes v p
WS v NP k tom mentioned it and i don't
have to define it ok what we know it's
an important problem it's like the holy
grail of algebraic complexity see yes
short version of this when I consider so
that right side when I have linear forms
yes just linear operator from M by M and
biomatrix done by amethyst so what is
inside well the determinant is a linear
operator yes
when biometric system so now is there
positive version of this conjecture so I
only want to do for permanence of
positive semi-definite maybe not that I
know of and the operator is completely
positive which goes from M go to hell I
don't think there is anything of this
kind I've never encountered it
okay last line here I still have to
explain it there is this implication if
P is different from NP then it implies
VP different V and P well there is a
little problem here because here in this
model when you when you build such a
representation you can use any complex
numbers any complex constants and you
somehow you have to even eliminate it
and it's possible to do it under the G
general Riemann hypothesis using a
result by Pascal cuarón so there is this
implication and if you don't if you
don't allow crazy complex constants here
then you can have this even without so
so the the lesson is if you want to
separate three from NP we have to do the
separation we PV and P first so this is
just okay this was just the inter
introduction I think I assume you know
all this okay now let's move on to to
this geometric viewpoint which was
introduced by Kate on mammalian milling
so horny long time ago so he proposed to
study this problem from the point of
view of algebraic geometry and
representation theory but what should
mention that even before catanduva
Strawson in his work on by linear
complexity tensor rank where he already
realized that the main problem there can
be phrased as an orbit closure problem
so it's actually much older
disconnection
so good then let's start with the more
technical thing so that is this symbol
here sim and V star
what is it V is a finite dimensional
complex vector space and then I look at
the space of homogeneous polynomials of
degree n on B so functions from B to the
complex numbers so why do I write it in
this way so actually if you want to
technically understand our paper it's
important to have this viewpoint of
multi linear algebra one needs to
understand that this space of
homogeneous degree and polynomials are
symmetric tensors on these star B star
is the dual space so I decided to use
this notation it's better not to avoid
it okay so then there is the orbit so in
yes genius or nof degree and functions
from it you can think of it this way but
if technically in the paper it is needed
so then okay so are we in the morning he
had this notation M G so the group G
that we have a group action yeah GL v
acts on the space of homogeneous
polynomials just by linear
transformation okay and then in RV's
notation I would have if I copy set
notation I would have written M sub G of
F so this dot here just denotes the
linear action coming from the G but they
didn't want to use the mg because it
messes up little bit the notation so we
get the orbit so I have my polynomial I
perform all possible invertible linear
transformation of the variables i get
the orbit
okay so here concretely my vector space
is the space of complex n by n matrices
so the capital n is N squared I viewed
the determinant as an element here it's
just the degree and homogeneous
polynomial and square variables okay Oh
cliff good now now the object that we
want to understand where all the
difficulty lies is the orbit closure so
I of the determinant yeah you can take
your because you with respect to
Euclidean topology or the risk it's all
the same by general principles so and I
like to denote this with capital Omega
and it's like you know there is the
small Omega is the exponent of matrix
multiplication you don't know it there's
the big Omega for the big problem your
so we don't know it like okay this is
this Omega n so what do we know about it
actually very little so Omega 2 this is
very easy just to understand the notion
if N equals 2 the determinant is a
quadratic form in four variables it has
full it has full rank ok the orbit by
linear algebra will consist of all
quadratic forms of full rank if I go to
the closure I get all quadratic forms so
I get here I will get the whole space of
quadratic forms this is very easy so if
N equals 3 it's already more complicated
there is a paper by yes co-written Hahn
is a former PhD student of mine Pierre
Larry they determined it so the when you
go to the it's interesting to understand
what happens when you go to the boundary
what is the boundary
what kind of polynomials you add when
you what are the possible limits so they
proved Omega free it this boundary has
two irreducible components and you can
explicitly describe it for N equals 4
it's already unknown it's very
interesting problem and we have a
connect connect conjecture I think we
know what it is but the proof is somehow
related to sub problems related to read
uses of schemes and so so maybe this can
be may be Omega 4 can be determined
but when M is 5 or bigger that becomes
quite while the problem okay when you
say no what do you mean I know this no
okay I can describe it completely the
boundary Wow after the boundary has yeah
it's the union of two or B closes and I
can describe it to you what it is but
maybe after the talk okay good so okay
now the permanent in this world the okay
I have my perm M then I do I have
another integer n bigger than M and now
I will multiply this permanent with with
the power of this linear form x11 and I
view it as an element of big space so
the point is in this face of the right
hand side there sits the determinant at
n but M can be much smaller than n so
the permanent is not an element of this
space so at one way to make this an
element is to multiply with this power
of the linear form we call this the
padded permanent right and there is this
conjecture so I decided to give names to
all these theorems and projections make
it easier I want to call it all the
closure conjecture
I made it up for this talk so that's
maybe k-town calls it GCT conjecture so
whatever
so it just states that we what this
thing is contained in Omega n if n is
sufficiently big and this all recursion
conjecture says this and the smallest
possible n has to grow super
polynomially studio this is the same and
right it's easy to see that this orbit
closure conjecture implies the variant
conjecture but the orbit that's what
kept on explained to us it's it's all
because of conjecture is a heart of sing
but it seems unavoidable from the point
of techniques that we have in mind so I
want to resolve this Orbitz closure
conjecture okay
any questions so far
so then let's move on to this
representation theory so I have my group
grv it acts on the space of homogeneous
polynomials okay then the next object I
believe we'll be looking at is the
coordinating of this thing so this is a
vector space and what is the corded ring
which I denote by this symbol it's just
the space of polynomial functions on
this
okay so polynomial function taking as
inputs themselves polynomials so
mathematically using this language from
multilinear algebra this is this object
the direct sum over all degrees the same
the same n this is the object this
object here is called the prices okay so
this is a prices and good so I view this
as a module over this group G and we
know Jia V is a reductive group which
means that every finite dimension module
is a direct sum of irreducible ones or
maybe I should say representation so
this somehow splits and it is also known
that I hope you you know this that the
irreducible GLD module in a way you
understand them we can classify them
they are called vile modules and they
are parametrized by partitions
partitions and it turns out okay maybe
the next here is a partition okay in
example a partition five-three-one is it
decreasing sequence of integers usually
it's written as a diagram so the five I
encode in this way I have a row
consisting of bat five boxes and a row
consisting of three boxes your BOM box I
think of the partition as a diagram is a
young diagram and what we know here the
the while modules occurring here must be
labeled by partitions of
sighs T times n I should define what is
the size the size written with absolute
rest is just the number of boxes it is
known that this must be a multiple of
must be T times n the length of the
partition is the number of rows and what
we also know this thing the number of so
the lengths of the partitions that occur
here is bounded by the dimension of the
group which is n square my general
principles so it always takes a long
time to explain the setting we need not
talk about this thing so please we have
stable C Omega n is the coordinate ring
of my orbit closure
okay now the idea is what is the idea so
how can you understand this chord in the
train so here is a simple thing so I
just look I make a restriction I have
the big space is the space here of the
homogeneous seam and V Star and I can
just restrict polynomial functions on it
I can restrict to Omega n so this gives
the subjective homomorphism which is
equivalent ok so I can view this as a
homomorphic image of this polynomial
ring and then I will say ok this is a
very important notion for the rest of
the talk I say a partition occurs in the
coordinate ring of Omega n if this thing
contains a copy of this valve module
no of notation I know so now let me
explain what is an obstruction they do
it in the context of the permanent so I
played the same game with the headed
permanent I have to pet it permanent
here I look at the orbit closure this
now depends on two parameters and and
Emin that just denoted Z&M okay then the
strategy what do we want to do we want
to show actually that this padded
permanent is not contained in omega n so
let's assume the contrary let's assume
it is contained then of course since
because this thing is invariant I can
conclude if this is the case then the
CMM is contained in omega n so I have
this contained containment of orbit
closures then I go to the coordinate
rings and I gave give get a subjective
ring homomorphism which is equivalent
then I use shoes lemma so if so I think
of these spaces now they take i
decompose them into irreducible and then
I know the specials lemma if some if
lambda occurs on the right hand side the
must have occurred on the left hand side
it's the very general principle okay and
the partition lambda violating this
condition is called an occurrence
obstruction that's what we are looking
for two currents obstructions okay if I
have an occurrence obstruction then I
have proved that znm is not contained in
Omega n so this is was the plan
I should notice here at this point that
Jules lemma actually gives more
information it gives an inequality of
multiplicities what I will not discuss
this any further a partition violating
this inequality is a multiplicity
obstruction so Christian in his talk he
will okay elaborate on multiplicity
obstructions
so the main result so what okay what is
the main result of the talk so there was
this conjecture in GC t 1 GC t - I don't
know
my kata and Milind I call it occurrence
obstruction conjecture it okay you read
it for yourself but basically it says
one can resolve the or because your
conjecture by means of appearance
obstructions okay so this was the the
hope and by what I explained right
before using Shor's lemma your current
obstruction conjecture implies the orbit
close or conjecture
okay and the main result is of this
paper
unfortunately the occurrence obstruction
conjecture is false so this is the
theorem Christian Agrippa
let's have a look at it what does it say
precisely so I have my parameters M and
M so let's assume M is greater equal m
to the 25 then I take any lambda should
be the size should be a multiple and
let's say n times T then if lambda
occurs in the correct ring of znm then
lambda also occurs in the core during of
the determinant
as the occurrence obstruction conjecture
is false sorry I'm going to discuss this
yes
okay just patient okay first let me
mention that before this paper there was
another paper by Christian and Greta
they had a similar result which stated
which said that the orbit closure
conjecture cannot be resolved to your
Chronicle coefficients so I don't have
time to go into this it's another story
but it was this result before which
already contained many of the ideas of
the proof and now right I will discuss
this before I talk about the proof let
me discuss what this actually means not
all proof yeah so let me discuss you
will see that
what can have okay what could have the
following idea instead of thinking about
the permanent versus determinant one
could also think about other complexity
measures let's have a look at the
so-called warring rank what is the war
in rank or symmetric tensor rank I have
a polynomial P a homogeneous polynomial
then it's known I can always write it as
a sum of powers of linear forms it's no
not the question is what is the minimal
number of terms and this is called the
boring rank or symmetric tensor rank now
I think it is quite well-known here that
one can actually put exponential lower
bounds on the war in the rank of the
determine on the permanent using the
partial derivative matrix it's in the
paper by normally sound paper RV and I
think this is quite known so then the
question is can we prove such bounds on
the warning ring by you know by
obstructions let's have a look so so one
way to see it is the following let's
take this power sum here the x1 up to xn
square of the variance and it has this
thing so what I do now I replace the
determinant by this power song okay and
then I play the same game I take the
orbit the orbit closure
let's see noted like bps like power song
okay
what do we do then we ask can we somehow
prove with our methods that the paddy
Perlman is not contained in this the
corollary is this and I think of you for
pointing this out comes out of the proof
the statement of this color is basically
the same as for permanent versus
determinant you read it for yourself
what does it say you cannot separate
using obstructions so the strategy of
occurence obstructions cannot even be
used in this week model of the PSM
against petty polynomials even more I
mean that's what I've written here so
what what I have done here I have
replaced the determinant by the power
some much simpler polynomial this the
determine how about the permanent now
this is the question by claim is it
important well no you can replace the
permanent here by any homogeneous
polynomial of degree M in M Squared is
any you have the same set because of the
padding this is yeah so in a way it's a
very strong result of weakness of the
method oh I don't know how to phrase
this yeah but the power variable to the
missing the Greek okay baby says it
whenever you can because you don't need
necessarily not your right is not
necessarily about that or the
obstruction the corollary is for the
padded version or the and or any any
version so neither the permanent when
you say the permanent in this example
okay I mean what is what I'm saying is
the CNMI defined before it was the or
it's the only closure of the pair is
permanent I can replace it but your
record of any homogeneous polynomial of
degree M in M squares just replace the
parent by anything but do the padding
this is a central for the proof okay
okay I'm using up too much time so now I
want to in the next part I want to
outline the proof what are the
ingredients
okay the proof is quite
tricky you don't throw it out I don't
know so I don't say anything about it
so so if you want to read the paper so
we have a section to with an overview of
the proof and I think it should be quite
accessible I'm not trying to explain
what is in this overview of the proof so
the first ingredient is an observation
going back to Cartesian Landsberg so
what does it say so I have a diagram
given by a partition lambda then I can
remove the first rows and then what I
get I I will call it the body I call
this the body of the diagram but you
noted by a lambda bar so then Cartesian
Landsberg they noted the following so
let's assume some lambda here occurs in
the coordinate ring of znm okay then two
things hold first of all the length of
lambda which is the number of rows it is
lost M square this was known before
second the body of lambda is at most has
size at most M D so it has a small body
think of and being much bigger than M
that's what we had in mind this
condition here that the small body is it
has the most decides it's equivalent to
saying that the lambda one the first row
is at least M minus M times D so it
means the lambda has a very long first
row very long first row a little bit of
body and not many rows okay so this is
this is a consequence of the padding is
a very strong assumption and this is a
main ingredient of the proof
so and this is the only information we
exploit about the or because of the
padded permanent so you can yes so if
you put it differently suppose you
didn't have the variable but you just
put diagonal copies of the permanent and
over m times instead right then the
proof doesn't work you cannot rule out a
reduction V algorithm it's very
important to have this power of the
linear form yeah so you don't know I
mean but that's a very nice Christmas
yeah so what would you put the permanent
n over m times diagonally not formations
to the terminal even we are okay yeah I
would have to think about doesn't come
out of this argument
good question it's a good question
that's a good question yes the
dependence of the form of credit is yeah
it's a it's very relevant it's very
relevant for the proof may be this can
also be excluded but this would did some
thinking okay so as I said before I
can't replace the permanent and maybe I
should also mention that this card isn't
lunch where property was also crucially
used in the paper by a Christian and
greater so okay second ingredient very
general it's the circle semi group
property so somehow in order to prove
the theorem you need to show for many
lambda that they occur in the quadrant
ring of the in the Omega of the Omega n
so how do we do this the strategy is
that first we establish for certain
shapes of lambda that they occur and
then we combine it and the combination
works with the semi group property and
here's the semi group property just says
if lambda occurs Mew occurs then lambda
plus nu occurs and the proof is very
simple if you know about highest weight
vectors you have a highest weight vector
for lambda back highest weight let the
function say one form you just take the
product
for those who know so it's not it's not
a difficult thing this also this
property was used in the paper while
greater question is addition so meaning
okay if you think of the partition is a
topple then it's the addition
component-wise okay okay so what are the
page okay now I have to tell you what
that is spacing building blocks so there
comes the connection to the invariant
theory so I'm thinking of okay as a
diagram I will take a rectangle that I
possibly extend so maybe the okay if the
rectangle but then I have maybe a longer
first row so there is this notation
which is not 2 K times L stands for the
diagram K times LD k rows of length L to
which a row has been appended so I get a
total of n K boxes here is an example
three times four you can see it here the
rectangle and then I add a couple of
boxes here in the first row so then I
have the following result it's maybe an
ingredient I call it row extent
proposition row extended rectangles and
it says the following
whenever okay I whenever the L is even
and n is greater equal K times L and
this thing this diagram occurs in the
quarry during of Omega n okay overs okay
I will tell you later on the idea of how
we prove this so this extended
rectangles always occur if n is
sufficiently big and DL is even
okay and actually now here I can also
explain the connection to the power son
because how do we prove this the only
property of Omega n that we use for
proving this proposition is that the
Omega n contains many Paddy Power's ohms
okay and this follows okay here is the
proposition from the universality of the
determinant so I wrote it here as a
proposition so what do we have here x +
5 on up to 5 K on linear forms so I I
take here power some then I pad it ok
and the statement is this thing is
contained in Omega n if n is greater we
go SK and what is behind is just this
inside going back to Leslie Balian
saying that if you have a you have a
polynomial and what the formula size is
say strictly less than L you can get it
as a projection of an L by L determinant
okay
now you just see this saying the formula
the formula sides of this thing is easy
to control that's all okay right so good
so now what is the strategy of the proof
so I only will talk about the case where
lambda is even meaning that all of the
components of lambda even so all the row
lengths are even numbers so I have such
an even partition and is greater equal m
to the 25 I know that lambda occurs in
the quarry ring of znm and I want to
show me the curves here so how do I do
it first step is the cottage Lordsburg
observation which I have reproduced here
second step I okay there are two cases
to distinguish case one is when the
degree is large so the D is the degree
okay
I call this degree let's say greater
than this so if the D is large then we
do the following as in the paper by
Creighton Christian we okay we remove
the first
lambda so then you get the body and then
I did compose the body into a sum of
even rectangles this is very easy so
just cut it okay then you see four for
each okay but this decomposition of the
body I have to get back at the
composition of the lambda and this is
possible if lambda if the first row of
lambda sufficiently large so this
involves some technique of some
calculation I don't want to do it but I
wrote it here I can write actually
lambda as the son of Rho extended
rectangles because NT are sufficiently
large and then I apply this proposition
row extended rectangle I know all these
extended rectangles occur in the coding
of Omega n I apply the semigroup
property and I see that the lambda
occurs okay so that's the idea
this is case one how about case to case
two is the heart I believe with the
degree is small then what do we do
so do you have you have another result I
called it all I don't know I didn't
couldn't figure out the better layer
that's the proposition all but what does
it say now I have a partition again I
have a bound on the size of the body and
I assume MD square less than Rico M okay
and if this under this assumptions and
the proposition says every highest
weight vector of weight lambda I will
define what it is but every highest
weight vector of weight lambda in the
places viewed as a degree D polynomial
function on this space doesn't vanish on
Omega and every in particular if lambda
occurs here and seemed the same n then
it occurs in the core adran of Omega n
as OD this is the statement of this
proposition
so this okay the proof of this
proposition what is behind well we had
to develop some insights regarding class
systems I think these are new
mathematical insight so I will call it
lifting higher straight vectors in
places and it is related to step the non
stability properties of classicism so I
hope I have time to explain a little bit
what is behind this okay
okay then I yes this was all for the
case of even partitions if I have
general partitions we need okay there
are two things we need more building
blocks so so so far I had a rectangle
with a standard first row but for the
general case we also need to extend by
column so you have and more tricks I
mean it's a bit more complicated I don't
want to go into it so this is so this
was the strategy okay now let me go a
little bit more to the details so it has
a lot to do with invariant theory but
first let me define what is the highest
weight vector I use this word already
several times without defining it now I
want to define what it is so how can we
show that lambda occurs in this
coordinate ring of Omega and so we do it
we are highest weight vector so what is
the highest weight vector in this
context so it will be an element of the
same DC men and the property is well
instead of looking I have here I have
the action of the group GL n but now I
will go to the sub group of upper
triangular matrices okay and actually I
want to have two properties I can go to
the sub group of upper triangular
matrices where there are ones on the
diagonal it's called unipotent group the
first condition is my F should be an
invariant under this group under the
unipotent group but also I want to have
this nice property
with regard to the action of diagonal
matrices they can be all combined by by
this formula so I have here an upper
triangular matrices the T's are on the
diagonal I act ok on F what I get is a
multiple of F ok and right so in a way I
say the F is an eigen vector of the I
have old I have the collection of all
these linear operators each upper
triangular matrix keys give me an
operator and F is a simultaneous eigen
vector for all of this and these are the
eigen values they depend
definition now you see special case if
the lambdas are all equal okay then what
I have here is the product of the T's in
parentheses to the lambda one but the
product of the t's is one because when I
okay Ben I assume that the determinant
of this matrix is 1 so f is invariant
under the action of huh of upper
triangular matrix of determinant 1 if
this holds and okay with a little bit
more theory one can show if if all these
lambda are equal it's even invariant
under the full SLN it's five minutes
okay I have to run okay all right
okay now are you my new my F I hope okay
there's another important it's hard to
explain this thing here okay
this symmetric tensor I view as a
homogeneous polynomial of degree n on
this space and the essential observation
is if okay if F evaluated at P is
nonzero then lambda will occur here the
coded ring of the orbit closure so this
is the strategy I don't have time to
explain why okay but then let me go
quickly do okay what are fundamental
invariants the question is what do we
know about the invariance of this space
here
there is a result you can go to how
saying that if T is less than capital n
there are no nonzero invariants but if T
equals n that is exactly one as Ln
invariant exactly one up to scaling I
like to call it the fundamental
invariant it was already know to Kaylee
okay Cayley already had found this some
hyper determinant so I can write down
what it is okay so I view this invariant
as a homogeneous degree n map goes from
here to here and then what does it do
okay so I evaluate my F at this
polynomial which I have written as a
symmetric tensor so I wrote write it
this way and this is the coefficient
tensor it's a symmetric tensor okay it
looks like this so if you see okay I'm a
little bit short of time but you see it
looks a little bit like determinant okay
it looks a little bit like a determinant
and actually there are two things the
first thing is it is an invariant it's
this wonderful property F of G applied
to P equals F P multiplied by this power
of the determinant and if capital if N
equals two actually this specializes to
the determinant up to a factor okay
this is easy to see so then what we do
how do we use this so I mean how can we
establish the existence of this pacing
building blocks well what do I do I take
this F I try this and I try to evaluate
the pian try to show it's nonzero but
it's harder and then it might make look
so here is an example there you see the
problem so let's take the special case F
n n is sinh evaluate at the product of
variables okay then if you check this
out it's easy then you realize what you
get is this the number of Colin even
Latin squares minus the number of column
or Latin squares whatever this is okay
you have to show this is nonzero
actually sorry this is a
and okay we want to this I I wanted
right here nonzero it's open and this is
an unknown conjecturing combinatoric sis
called alone tarsi conjecture alone
Darcy conjectures community Oryx says if
n is even that the number Colin even
lattice squares differs from the number
of column or letting squares so even in
this very simple case here we don't know
the answer so so what we did then how
okay so the how did we save this it's
the following observation instead of
taking this product of variables let's
take the power some if I have my F and n
my fundamental invariant I evaluate at
the power some I can prove it's nonzero
the way this is done I mean you look at
what this means and unfortunately all
the signs get plus so in a way you have
a sum of squares and you could prove
there is no cancellation so actually
this idea of doing this is we did it
first in a paper with mattias crystals
together so this is one you see one
technical tool where we yeah I'm almost
done few words about the lifting yes
there was this complicated proposition
on the I don't have time to do to
explain anything because I'm over time
anyway but mathematically what we added
here was we constructed a lifting map so
from Cindy M to semen and so you see
this M gets bigger so we constructed a
map a linear map somehow I don't have
time to explain all the details which
had married okay what were the
properties so this map Kappa maps
highest weight vectors to highest weight
vectors
and what we also did we came up with a
list of Jimmy the generating system of
these representations so the generators
are labeled by certain tableau VT and
then we could explain what happens under
this map so the VT goes to a VT prime
and we can combinatory describe how you
get T Prime from T which is a very nice
and clean description it's very common
at Oriel okay right so aside okay maybe
I can say it was known in combinatorics
that these dimensions of under certain
constraints the multiplicities do not
change when you go from here to here but
for our proof it was I mean what is the
new ingredient mathematically is the
description of the highest weight vector
so you have more information on these
Playstations than were known before this
was essential for our proof okay nice
ink as I'm I skipped the proof of the
proposition I was true to complicated it
I want it I was hoping I could go
through the proof of this proposition
explain it but it's too hard so then I
think I stop here and there you can ask
questions thank you
[Music]
let's get back to the chili for moi
Amy yeah yeah yeah the wonderful
invariant
and here's the story on story this is
actually what they call thumper
ha ha so now that the relic several ways
to write the proof of the scaling
algorithm operator scaling algorithm are
being myself on kidnapping one purpose
to use capacity okay I also get the
probe which use that thing okay what is
that idea that topic rate the scaling
business thing so they think is
responsible when you have four indices
for polynomial identity chip
this was the environment actually which
started holder to forget the scale is
respondent permanent so now what is the
proof of that you believed you take the
stairs ring and at some point that lift
using Carson makes the same positive and
then okay and because it integer it
would be same way it gives the bound on
the capacity okay so you might think
that they essentially the proof of the
algorithm is combining one of do it the
bindings this one with lifting so you
are saying there is very deep connection
there it's I understand you're saying in
the analysis of your algorithm in your
paper you use you use this invariant
yeah for the analysis who calls it
Pascal ha okay I know
okay so maybe I have a question so here
you were actually saying not just that
the permanent is hard but basically
under this notion you're not gonna get
occurrence obstructions for any function
any product can you elaborate this way
so I'm curious now if you're starting to
looking looking at multiplicity
obstructions or DCT in general is there
a general way by which you can say that
the random function is odd
yeah that's a that's a very good
question and I don't think that and this
is the most natural thing we know I mean
we know the lower bounds on generic
forms of generic tensors but don't think
so because this can only I mean this can
only work for those objects that are
characterized by its symmetry group so
what if you have a random object is not
characterized think his question is can
we I think the question is whether DCT
approach is complete let's say with what
I understood but his quest mother's
question is whether one is can one proof
elope
I try to see whether understand your
question Cameron you proved using GCT a
lower bound on generics random functions
no it is for a current abstraction well
for in this padded setting its it is
planet setting I mean what I want to
know if it's
but you could go to multiplicity
obstructions and it's I think for
multiplicity we know very little about
multiplicity obstruction but there is a
result probably greater we'll talk us
about talk about this what we can say
when there is no padding what happens